but we begin this morning with the
latest in the nation's battle against
the corona virus outbreak there are now
more than 51 thousand deaths from kovat
19 in this country
president Trump signed a four hundred
eighty four billion dollar relief
package on Friday it aims to bolster
testing efforts hospital costs and make
low-interest loans available to small
businesses this says stay at home orders
are loosened in Alaska Georgia and
Oklahoma other states are expected to
start relaxing restrictions in the
coming days in California there are
concerns the 80 plus degree temperatures
expected this weekend will attract
crowds to the beaches and beachgoers did
swarm to the sand in Southern California
Friday but did seem to maintain distance
Michael George begins our coverage in
hard-hit New York City this morning
Michael good morning good morning Dana
here in New York doctors are seeing a
decrease in cases but still six thousand
new patients are coming into hospitals
every day health experts say that New
York can't reopen without widespread
testing but in some states governors are
saying the time to reopen is now ready
or not businesses in some states are
reopening the trust in main salon run by
Tara Glen in Georgia
is one of them but not all Georgians
agree protesters showed up Friday
outside governor Bryan Kemp's home is
his order to open up went into effect
Oklahoma and Michigan also had limited
reopening Friday and Monday Tennessee
Minnesota and Colorado will join them in
Nebraska governor Pete Ricketts is in
the process of green-lighting
non-essential businesses so they can
operate but not necessarily as usual so
the hairstylist will have to wear a mask
the tattoo artists will have to wear a
mask and so will the person who is being
served the customer we have found a way
to safely allow low-risk construction
that is underway to resume even governor
jay Inslee of hard-hit Washington State
put a crack in his stay at home order
but the day of reopening our whole
economy certainly is not today it would
be way too dangerous
and all of our data shows that if we did
this today this virus would return with
a vengeance and an overwhelming majority
of Americans agree according to a
variety of new opinion polls the CBS
News poll found 70 percent of Americans
believe the country's top priority
should be slowing the spread of Kovan 19
by staying at home 30 percent say
working and the economy are more
important that as get back to work
demonstrators continued to steal
headlines this week but they haven't
convinced a majority in the country
polls show the CBS News poll found
Americans give high marks to those who
are staying home 73 percent are proud of
people staying home and also proud of
doctors nurses and first responders and
people who deliver and provide food the
chef was an essential person Rhonda
Adkins pizzaz deli and kitchen supply in
Great Falls Montana has been providing
take home meals since March 28th she's
expecting customers to walk in any day
now there's excitement of course because
it's like spring break or summer
vacation now well we're finally released
and then back to trepidation well with
everybody out will they become careless
even here in a state that's had fewer
than 500 cases there's uncertainty
Lisette Carter is a lifelong Montana who
retired from her own construction
company am I worried
I wear my gloves in my mask but I'm old
shity probably and doctors here in New
York just got the results back from the
first large-scale antibody test and it
showed that nearly 14 percent of New
Yorkers showed signs of past infection
which indicates that many people got
kovat and didn't show any symptoms
another indication experts say of the
need to continue social distancing Jeff
okay Michael thank you very much